i also think that what donald trump just
by his very nature
represented was the refutation
of the the whole system and that that in
a way was a threat to them and also the
fact that they they told everyone
well look we've laid out these rules we
represent the american people we know
what they think they'll never vote for
this guy and then they voted for this
guy
and now they all look bad because they
told you this couldn't possibly happen
and the truth is it's like this whole
thing man it's like
there's like levels of irony and tragedy
it's something
it's like a greek tragedy that the
country
so hated clinton bush
obama establishment they failed so much
of the country they squandered the
greatest country on earth
but the only thing we had that could
actually beat them
was donald freaking trump yeah and we
everyone
wanted him to be something else like the
left wanted him to be hitler
the right wanted him to be the caesar
yeah and he's just
donald trump well so so i think it was
cernovich you said uh you know like so
the left wants him to be hitler the
right wants him to be caesar and
cernovich said he's a kardashian
yeah but that's right that's a great
that's a great
the people looked at what they were
given and they said i'll take donald
trump think about what that means now
i've long said the way i view the trump
presidency and why i thought it made
more sense to support him was that you
have the ivory tower
you have the establishment elites
looking down and scoffing and laughing
at the little people as they use
the working class people's children as
cannon fodder
and they're laughing and then along
comes bernie sanders
left populist and donald trump right
populist and
they're banging on the doors well they
said hey bernie
come on up don't worry we'll be nice to
you and he was like oh gee they're
looking
and then he joins on in the trump people
broke the door down
trump storms in and he's like a raging
bull knocking things over flipping
tables screaming at everybody and they
were freaking out
oh heavens oh and they're fanning
themselves and running from the tower
and then they desperately needed to get
it back so i look at the trump
presidency as fairly chaotic
we had a really really great economy in
2019 the best numbers of our lives
and i said this in a previous episode
well i i asked i think i asked luke to
try and coax him into saying it
isn't trump our greatest greatest
president of our lifetimes and i'm like
you're like but when you look at no new
wars
and you at least look at the attempts to
withdraw troops from some of these
places
it is far from perfect but you look at
clinton bush and obama
so he's half as bad as the other ones or
he's uh
as good as he promised to be but again
it's still i think he brought up a good
point
you you bring up the bull analogy but
they also contained him in the lower
level so he couldn't get anywhere else
up and they he he
and he he raged but he raged in the gift
shop
he didn't rage in the actual positions
that actually mattered
and in my opinion he kind of like just
put the establishment
at half pace of where they were going
anywhere he held him back
and he held them back halfway but the
establishment was still moving in
uh prairie fairly close with him and now
they're going to go full steam ahead
with joe biden and i do think there's
going to be new conflicts
uh engaged all throughout the world
specifically also
around russia uh they're going to try to
kind of also they're going to bump heads
with china but i think biden has too
many ties to china to actually do
anything legitimate china is going to
expand its territory i think it's very
fair to say that
but they're going to be butting heads
very seriously
uh in other places in the world like
ukraine
syria who knows turkey is also a very
hot location
that's in conflict with greece right now
so there's a lot of potential for
conflict all over the world stage and i
think a biden
administration is going to exploit that
to the fullest extent because he has the
top echelons of the military-industrial
complex
in his cabinet in his administration and
you know at the end of the day
they're the ones who are going to be
calling the shots and they do call the
shots
i i i have to wonder about all of these
people who constantly think there's this
grand plan
you know like the like not necessarily
the cue people but the periphery to them
as well
that are like i can see what's happening
their comments i see pop up where
they're like
you know trump didn't really concede he
said a new administration which means
he's replacing pence and it's like dude
like trump i thought was way better than
hillary clinton
it's not hard to be way better than
hillary clinton she was awful
like one of the worst politicians to
ever run and just this demanding
and sickly individual is just and she
wanted it and we we had a choice between
the establishment over and over and over
again
and there was an opportunity for a trump
and he and he and he managed to pull it
off well i mean
trump's whatever far from perfect but
whatever criticism you could
you could uh launch at trump and there's
a lot uh
donald trump uh made it
that we didn't have another bush or
clinton and for that alone
yeah for that president he should be
saluted
just for beating the bushes and the
clintons and destroying those two
evil you know like uh um family
organizations criminal organizations and
look i'll say this
i think uh barack obama was an
absolutely horrible president but you
know what because of him john mccain
wasn't president
and oh my god if you want to see a
disaster let
john mccain have access uh to to be the
commander-in-chief of the military i
mean we'd probably be in five more wars
if he had been there so now obama did
pretty much get
five more this is the main problem
though like i think
trump i i think trump operated in good
faith when he got in
he thought that he was president now and
you know people were going to listen to
him and that he was going to have
control and get to do the things that he
wanted
fulfill his promises and these wars and
he didn't realize he was walking
into a gigantic machine all gummed up
with bureaucracy and red tape
okay but that's on him see the problem
no but the problem with donald trump
okay is that he doesn't know
anything about anything there's not
one thing he's ever read a book about
and knows something about it he's got
instincts he's instinctually brilliant
in many ways
but dude he banned critical race theory
being uh like taught to the military and
in government organizations
and through contracts because three
months ago he was watching fox news
and saw a thing about critical race
theory and went what's this critical
race theory thing
that sounds stupid let's stop doing it
he had no clue what it was up until that
point
so that's the problem and at the debate
he couldn't define it
yeah yeah oh no i'll take it yeah well
look i agree
it's still better than nothing but it's
kind of like but dude to rise to the
level
to actually do what he could have done
the person he could have been in history
he needed to know like three things
and he knew nothing i think it's
obviously hyperbole he doesn't know
anything
i think the dude's clearly successful
became president he's very rich and the
problem was he entered government
thinking it would work like a business
he thought he could just fire people he
couldn't do it he surrounded it he hired
bad people and the one thing he was
famous for firing people he didn't do
enough of
he hired people and fired his own people
when he should have been firing all
these holdovers
who are going behind his back leaking
information and sabotaging everything
he overspent that's another thing if he
was running it if he was running it like
a business
the business is gravely in debt right
now that our children's children are
going to be paying for
and also when you look at the people he
surrounded himself with the ones that he
took advice from
i mean jared kushner the one who
negotiated better weapons deals for
saudi arabia ivanka
the lady who cried about the alleged
chemical weapons attack in syria that
many
investigations proved not to be true
that convinced him to bomb syria
according to
trump's son who admitted that this
happened i mean come on i mean
no no now i gotta say though i gotta say
you're doing a lot of ragging on the guy
the abraham accords are amazing
yeah i don't think so no i no fair
enough i would just say i was actually
going to defend him in that moment too
that i will say the
one one defense i'll give to donald
trump for putting his family uh in these
positions that they were not in any way
qualified to be is that
he really had he really had no one he
could trust and they did try to frame
the guy for treason
for three years and he had the entire
deep state working against him so i
think he did want his family there
because he's like okay well at least
ivanka is not going to like
be setting me up for you know like she
set him up to bomb syria but look
for for all the issues too jared kushner
helped negotiate these historic peace
agreements
yeah look when i think the peace
agreements to be honest i i like the
sound of it i think they're kind of
overplayed
there's not really any meaningful peace
uh between
people who were not already allies it's
like okay you can make this
normalization of
of economies new flights not now planes
from from
one arabic country can fly over israel
look it's it's not an easy good it's not
an easy process
so i remember when donald trump crossed
the dmz into north korea
and he was heavily criticized for it and
i said all he was doing was endangering
the country and negotiating with a
dictator and i'm like dude
negotiations had to start somewhere yeah
if we get bahrain
and the emirates and uh you know
now you've got uh uh morocco and they're
normalizing relations
that's the first step i listen i agree
that's and and that's more than
what happened for obama but what
happened with the listen you're
absolutely right about the north korea
stuff it was great that he did that it
was amazing it was a great first step
and what happened with those
those trade negotiations this idiot made
john bolton the national security
adviser
and sent him over there to blow the
whole thing
yeah yeah and then sabotage that
and that is on trump of course i mean
like who in the right mind would put
this
guy because this is another thing that
people really need to think about donald
trump set up a peace deal that was
almost
identical to the same iranian peace deal
that he wanted north korea to have so he
ended one piece deal
and he wanted another one that he
unsuccessfully didn't get and we're
going to have a biden
administration that's going to do the
opposite and it's like they're playing
with us they're
toying with us you know look over here
but on the other end they commit
something
as we can clearly see from these reports
assuming the mitch mcconnell one is true
trump trusted way too many republicans
thinking that they were going to work
with him and what they wanted was judges
and then they gave him bad info bad
people and they just were waiting him
out and now i do believe they want to
purge him
and all of his supporters but like you
said the people still love the man
yeah and i think i think you know why i
think when you listen to him
i think trump does want to help people i
just don't think he understands how
government works
yeah you might be right i don't actually
know what he wants and i gotta say i'm
starting to think more and more that he
really just
wants to help himself but i will say
that
the donald trump looked at an entire
group of americans
who are just absolutely despised
by the ruling elite i mean they hate
these people
you don't have to watch cnn for more
than 10 minutes to just gauge
what they think of the average trump
supporter they hate these people
they lecture them all day long they
don't care as you pointed out they use
their kids as cannon fodder
they they don't care that there's a drug
they barely even ever report on the drug
ods
on the suicide rate on the life
expectancy going down these people
have been completely screwed uh screwed
over by the empire just completely
forgot about and donald trump looked at
those people and said you know what
i care about you i want to bring your
jobs back i want to win for you
and that was enough that was all it took
because no one had ever talked to those
kids before it was like someone
showing like you know like the ugly girl
in high school a little bit of attention
and she was like i love you like that's
okay you're my i don't mean to insult
anybody but
i think i just insulted i think i just
alienated trump supporters and women
i think i lost i don't know who's left
but i'm just making the point that
he just he just didn't hate them you
know you'd see these pieces like on cnn
where they'd be like why do these
evangelicals support donald trump and
like kind of on the surface you could
see what they're talking about i mean
clearly the guy's not a devout christian
um but you know why they support him
because he doesn't
hate their guts yeah and you do and he
does
he eats steak with ketchup and michael
michael moore made those same exact
points that you're
missing right now well that's this is my
favorite story that i remember when
donald trump went to this fancy
restaurant and he ordered like this 30
day dry
age steak super fancy and expensive well
done with ketchup
and i watched the media mock and laugh
and you know why that was so brilliant
on trump's part do you know what the
regular what regular
americans saw when they watched those
segments they weren't mocking and
laughing at trump they were mocking and
and laughing at you the regular
working-class american who's got only a
couple bucks to buy that garbage you
know steak from the supermarket
that you cook it all the way through and
you put ketchup on it because it tastes
like crap yeah
so i remember when i was growing up
guess what for the most part yeah we'd
get
you know grocery store cuts for a couple
bucks we'd cook them well we put ketchup
on it because we weren't rich
every so often we'd save up and my my
dad would come back with the filet
mignon and like this is the good stuff
and he put a little garlic and salt on
it and we just ate it like it was and it
was so amazing
and so i knew when i saw that story what
trump was doing whether he's all about
expensive well-done steaks with ketchup
or he knew i'm going to speak to these
people who have been kicked to the curb
and insulted and the media walked right
into it yeah
you know you know what it really comes
down to for me the media is despicable
it is it is the press in this country it
is lies all day and every day and that's
and i you know i grew up uh with the the
war in iraq
the lies from the media the the this
blind trust of government
and it got us into these wars and there
was no accountability for these people
many of whom are still working
these politicians who voted for it still
in office to 47 years
and that's that and that's why i say
it's kind of funny to say that donald
trump is the greatest president of my
lifetime
because he didn't vote for these things
he spoke out against them in his book
he did really poorly in hiring any and
he fumbled a lot
but he spoke to the people he did a lot
more than these elites did
he banned critical race theory whether
he knew about it or not i liked it and
it was only in the past year or so when
i was like i like what i'm seeing right
now
i like the attempts at least to mock the
establishment
you know what i really like i i'm with
you completely on that but that was a
great gift that he gave us
just relentlessly mocking the the
corporate press you ever see you ever
see the
the moment where he comes out and he's
like you know by the helicopter and the
press all asking him questions
and he's like we got a really great deal
saudi arabia is giving us billions of
dollars for all these weapons
and the anti-war left their jaws hit the
floor like
he just comes out and says you're not
supposed to admit this it's supposed to
be
we're here to support you know security
and peace and trump's like we're getting
great money it's great for the economy
and then when it came to syria when this
when we left troops that regard the oil
fields he just comes out and says it
he's like you know we tried to get the
troops out of syria but i guess they got
mad at me so we just left in there
they're guarding the oil that's what
they wanted
and i'm just like tell the people but i
think that's
i think that's a big part of the reason
why he was so despised
uh is that he is this guy that just
is uncontrollable and he blurts things
out
donald trump can't keep a secret if he
wanted to you know there's no aliens
but but it's also why it scared the
bejesus
out of all of these people you know like
donald trump one of the people wonder
why uh you know like john brennan for
example hated donald trump you ever hear
john brennan on tv
you can tell it is a personal hatred
that he has for donald trump
well listen donald trump when he was
running in 2016
just blurted out okay that
obama armed isis and created that now he
just blurts this out he's just like you
know obama created isis that was all
obama
and they're like what are you talking
about you can't say that and he goes no
no no obama created isis
and saudi arabia did 911. he also blamed
them for 9 11.
now and he said he was going to end the
federal reserve no he said a lot of
these things
now john brennan was the head of the cia
while they were knowingly arming al
qaeda in iraq
also known as treason with a capital t
these are crimes that if you were uh
prosecuted for
the the punishment for treason i believe
last i checked
is death okay so trump is just out there
blurting it out and to trump he's like i
just said it now i move on and now i'm
going to talk about how great my crowd
is
he brings flinders but brennan's sitting
there like what did you just say
you're not supposed to say this and like
people who talk about this are like
like i talk about this a bit you talk
about this and stuff but the president
of the united states
with his 70 million adoring voters
and before that it was totally ignored i
mean we had whistleblowers we had
government agents we had
insiders we had people on the ground
that were confirming
showing videos showing photos showing
documents of us
arms munitions weapons trucks
going directly into the hands of isis
al-nusra and al-qaeda inside of syria
to do regime change and and this was
proven but this was only talked about in
the alternative press
until michael flynn
actually whistleblowed and released a
lot of the information michael flynn of
course was brought in by
donald trump and donald trump was saying
this on the public stage and then we
know what happened to
michael flynn yeah they got rid of him
and this is where the russian narrative
comes in he must be doing this because
he's trying to undermine and damage this
country
but it was look it because a lot of
people look at it on the
surface and they go oh well but the it
failed because they didn't get them you
know they got nothing off the mueller
report there was no one went to jail
but no it worked right they boxed him in
for three years
so donald trump was running on look
let's make a deal with russia
that way we both have a common enemy in
isis who cares if assad is is the the
president of syria like whatever we'll
just leave him there it's worse when we
overthrow these guys anyway
so we'll make a deal we'll make a deal
with russia will get out of syria
and then after hearing nothing but
trump-russia collusion
on repeat every day for years well now
trump can't make a deal with russia
because if he went and made a deal with
russia well then that's proof
that he's colluding with russia so it
works perfectly and it's all about
the qatar turkey pipeline and i
shouldn't say all about it's a large
component are you familiar with it yeah
yeah i've read a little bit about it so
there was a report from uh the guardian
going back to i think 2012
where they said that a report in 2009
from the u.s
said they wanted that we wanted to have
boots on the ground in syria because
bashar al-assad was blocking our access
to building this pipeline
lo and behold everything you guys just
talked about remember that that photo of
the truck
isis had and it's got like you know what
was it that truck that had the phone
number for like a michigan
auto mechanic i was like how did that
truck get there
that's not that's weird did you ever in
there
as well do you ever hear the the tape i
don't remember i'm not sure if it was a
hot mic or like a secret recording but
there's the tape of john kerry talking
about the rise of
of isis uh is really interesting uh
as he's talking about it so he comes in
i guess in was in 2013 he became
secretary of state says after hillary
clinton
left um and he's talking about so this
is kind of you know right as it's
happening
um and he's talking about and he's
basically just saying quite frankly
on this tape i think he doesn't realize
he's being recorded and he's going uh he
goes look we saw it
we saw the rise of isis coming but we
thought we could control it yeah
and use it to bring assad to the
negotiating table so you also
you got to understand with a lot of
these things it's tremendous hubris
that they think everyone's their pawns
and then because look it was not
part of the plan for isis to then go
invade iraq
have the shiite army that we trained
bail strip off their uniforms and hand
over all the stockpiled weapons to them
that wasn't part of the plan so they
just think that they can control
everybody in the same way that like the
black lives matter rioting
smashing up that cnn building wasn't
part of the plan you're like wait you
guys weren't supposed to do that
you were supposed to just go over here
but people are not pawns and it's not
always easy to control them so the whole
thing just got away from them well they
created
the cultural situation in iraq
especially with
the second gulf war after they got rid
of a lot of the hussein
baptist loyalists that they said no
longer could serve in the new military
so a lot of those fighters
joined up with more radical sunnis and
they were enabled to start
this larger group that later became
known as isis directly because of policy
decisions
by the bush administration specifically
making sure
uh that that this protocol was followed
it was it led to
tremendous amounts of human suffering i
mean people were
tortured on camera with amazing like
production that was terrifying the
entire world
the western world has been terrified but
i started adding up the numbers
we're getting to hitler stalin level
numbers i mean you're talking
a million in iraq half a million in
syria it's going to be a million in
yemen but this is the same one thing i
need to bring up here is because we had
isis literally dominating the headlines
everyone was always talking about them
everyone in the western world was scared
about a terrorist attack happening in
their city because of them
and their ideas they had the direct
fingerprints of all the upper echelons
of the u.s intelligence agencies
israel saudi arabia working with them in
cohesion and then
all of that just magically kind of went
away under the presidency of donald
trump who
who uh from the information i'm getting
stopped funding them no he's not
supporting
that was you want to give trump credit
for something that was one of the first
things he did
yeah he ended he ended the cia program
to arm the anti-assad rebels yes
and almost immediately after that isis
just stopped being a problem and there
was also and they also fought him i mean
that was like the russians were fighting
them and our troops were well the
russians were exposing how they were
selling oil syrian oil to turkey thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8 p.m so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time